previously on satisfactory and now
continuing I can't I can't explain how
angry no I'm gonna put it in do
something useful okay will murder your
face you know nobody asked me if I
wanted to push the button you said you
want to get in the pod well yeah and
then I realized that wasn't possible and
then just the button got pushed and I
wasn't really consulted and what's out
you know you're right mark should be
more considerate of people I shut up why
why did we pick the rocket it says I can
select another milestone but I don't
know if it's gonna clear out what we
just did if I select this oh yes please
delete the space rocket I don't want to
do that come on do it you know you want
to I just said I don't you want to know
I don't okay I don't listen very well I
mean you could literally wait three
minutes and then find out more carapace
is any more koop petite we're doing good
I need more carapace indeed holy [ __ ]
that's death whatevs we die where do we
go where we did know we'd its mysteries
of the universe really puzzle me you
know one mystery that doesn't puzzle me
is what happen I pressed the red button
because I got to press the red button do
you sleep who's dead I wanna [ __ ]
harvest our mass automatically goddammit
how would we do that I don't know I just
wanted your thing okay let me look
that's how we have to get power it
should be positive
there's milestones that will unlock new
things one was for conveyer splitter
merger one is for inventory stuff ones
for walls what are you doing nothing I
need to go to the bathroom
I'll be right back yeah you would okay
all right then I guess I'm on my own
maybe not here for you buddy I my own by
choice I'll come with you
whoa no you're not yeah whatever
happened I don't know what it was but
I'm happy about it oh it's coming back
hello what oh oh oh my god what the [ __ ]
what is it doing
oh it's landing those betraying us so
used to things betraying me just assumed
when have I ever betrayed you the last
three Half Men so given forget man what
was the point of waiting for maybe it
was uh it was a test launch to make sure
we could launch ourselves I'm not
looking for any philosophical [ __ ]
at this juncture wait that's a my cilia
why do you need my cilia why for the
next three search takes this you refused
to come in here and [ __ ] do it I
would have said anybody was researching
nuts you got your nose started
researching alien carapace level two why
you I could have here take your [ __ ]
shrooms you you clawed to take them I
hate you 86 I only needed five I hate
you hey Mark can you kill me no why
would I be able to heal you know maybe
you could give me your nuts I don't have
any nuts
you had the nice you've stuffed your
nuts in the machine oh I've got more now
that's fine you sound very bitter about
the fact that I totally blew you out of
the water by stealing your thunder
pressing the button yeah whatever you
know what whatever hey another button I
got it mine yes
I pushed about as you can press a button
my dad okay the same way
it's so beautiful now that I get to do
it oh how does it feel to be the silver
medal this bad [ __ ] you up
[Laughter]
stab you your big thick ass are you
leading me somewhere huh you leading me
towards the fire demons ha ha ha guys no
hugs that for me sweet thick legs yeah
you're not gonna have any balls anymore
you know what I'm doing with you they
can't protect you now
ha ha it's all behind that ass is mine
come on come on yeah yeah yeah whatever
now
yeah whatever now ha ha ha ha okay wait
all right cease fire cease fire cease
fire cease fire cease fire joke's on you
all right cease fire okay all right okay
okay that's cease fire that's it we got
work to do
we can't let Bob we can't let Bob come
back to us not getting any [ __ ] done
you're right
for the record out all right that hey
hey listen I am cease firing I know
just [ __ ] you're [ __ ] dead don't
kill me please no no no what hit left I
let you get too many sucker punches oh
my god no no no no nothing bad happened
to my unattended player we were a little
preoccupied it's okay no no no no no no
no no no no now you're done
are you glad yeah yeah well you know
what up now then let's say I had some
stairs unlock [ __ ] please I'm gonna
build some cool stuff no I'm good [ __ ]
you ha miss P yeah alright I'll leave
you I'll leave you I'll leave you I
won't kill you songs you don't exact
revenge we're done we're done
look at my tower what huh what what the
whoa holy [ __ ] Bob how are you even
getting stuff done well we've been not
getting stuff done
I definitely this is not cows getting
stuff done by I can see our whole
universe Wow look at how cool it keep
you guys away from my goddamn tower I'm
putting it away there I got a beacon now
is there fall damage yes there is father
huh oh hey you need a free and you get
free I'll free you all free you
I'll free you kind of freedom and how do
I get I can't get it wait I'm gonna come
for you oh oh god oh all right I know
what we need to do we need to launch the
spacecraft oh alright yeah you're right
you wait wait
we got I'm gonna find the least yeah
that's the edge of the spacecraft that
you're on we need a few more rods some
more I got the wire I think go pull wire
from the from the copper things wave
you've gotta stay on there we gotta see
if we can launch you please please
please please get like a full stack I
have 1,300 that'll do okay pop that in
there
I've got enough rods you can push the
button if you want wait but I want to
watch let me know when you get up there
go for it here three two one goodbye
wait Bob jump up there I'm going goodbye
oh god I'm going to space oh dear oh
[ __ ] no oh I'm not falling off I'm
actually going to star you I see a big
screen I can do stuff but I can't
respawn I think I see my own dead pink
icon was at the top of this I'm back
welcome back my skirt I'm alive again
welcome back buddy
all right how was your trip good I lost
everything that was in my inventory
which was all of the wire wait is your
corpse Hannah I see an icon for a corpse
maybe is it on the ship the ship's back
the icon seems to be the ship so I'm
pretty sure Oh is my corpse gonna be on
top of the ship I think yeah oh yeah
definitely
oh yeah hair
I want to get my stuff back
my zappy stick either wait it says
you're on the ship but I don't see your
body you can craft it is a pee stick ok
new at the workbench I don't see your
body experience that a learning moment I
guess so that's nice
so you took all the wire with you
correct wait I found it Syria more yeah
I had like all of it katti reom sounds
funny more what I mean like you did this
to yourself
goodbye whoa hi friend
ok yeah I see that body icon Oh bacon
agaric did you guys say you found bacon
earlier yeah someone it was bacon I
don't know what it was I'm gonna zap
before you add it reading no no there's
bits but it's a special glowy mushroom
called bacon agaric bacon agaric yeah it
heals two health bars sounds pretty cool
Bob where are you I don't see you
anymore I'm oh is my icon broken I'm Way
west side okay I'm gonna put a zapper in
the storage container for you when you
get back there's waterfalls over here
guys you seen the waterfalls yeah
everyone I was the only one doing
anything no no guys I have a thing
chasing me I need an adult you're right
there buddy i juking him I'm jumping
them I don't know what's happening to
either you guys I'm trying to actually
advance our progress in the game but you
guys seem to be putzing around I got I
got a hey I got seven no I got one Green
Power slug could Cape cater of deuterium
right that's a real thing
yeah okay alright yeah katti reom is
okay this for the first time ever among
our group Wayne when did you discover
the waterfalls like 18 hours ago
and I just discovered Couture iam but
that was like two seconds ago yeah
by discovered both that doesn't make any
sense that's not how discovering works
I'm a disc
her and I discovered both still doesn't
make this how it works I'm really not
following Wade your logic doesn't make
any sense well if you look to your left
and you raise your middle finger and you
pointed it yourself then you'll see that
oh yeah I suck and weights the best hmm
no that's not what I really saw there
we got logistics which means we can
split conveyors and merge conveyors now
I'm constructing biofuel out of the by
oles minor stuff that I have I don't
know what that does I'm guessing it's
just more dense energy so we don't have
to go back to these as many times oh it
is yes were you just gonna let me take
over that storage box that you just
crept it's for us what do you mean take
it over I mean I filled it completely
you know fine I do it's for us not
greedy I'm just needy just trying to get
to me now I'm gonna make a scanner nut
I'm gonna make a nut scanner there's no
nuts on this one but that's okay Cooper
mark you should have gone in the pooper
that was where he was playing a berry
berry Cramer man what's happening
am i twitching okay it was just looking
for nuts haha okay I'm gonna drop all my
[ __ ] i'ma drop all my [ __ ] toward the
leg juice yeah I'm just gonna keep
stacking them up oh hey he's alive no
I'm not I'm reviving you it's fun no you
can revive me it says I can but I'm not
Oh am i alive no I'm not
I'm glad to know that when I die you're
just gonna zap my corpse oh thanks
thanks so much
it's not doing hey I'm back
that was weird I don't need it I'm gonna
go find nuts with this we're yet what
zap oh yeah I probably actually that's a
good idea
thank you thanks to the nuts oh did I
have nuts like such a brick you guys
need to shush I'm trying to hear the
beeps not anymore
listen I'm trying to find us food so we
don't starve what about me okay yeah did
you run out here this way and pick all
the [ __ ] nuts
off every tree if you're running east or
west from there though probably running
south now Thanks thanks man whatever you
know just whatever
I'm just getting biomass for us oh [ __ ]
it's a boy
no don't push me off the ledge oh my
this this guy I was like looking over a
crevasse
I was like oh it's sooo very deep French
and then this this [ __ ] thing charts
almost knocked me in excuse me whoa what
is that oh is this an out am I an idiot
did you have some kind of trouble did
you find a flower that exploded into
bugs no no fire dude oh oh bird there's
like a lizard oh it's cute dog doesn't
want to be near me it's running oh pet
the lizard dog oh I found a I found a
lizard dog oh good it was a bum oh oh
yeah
jet you're probably laughing you give me
for being a [ __ ] right now I'm not a
[ __ ] I'm not a [ __ ]
guys you believe me right what's problem
there's a hole in the ground should I go
down here oh it's bloody oh this looks
bad
oh I made a mistake oh I can't get back
up Oh God oh no I'm in a cave I can't
get out oh no oh no all right I did it
somehow wait I'm not an idiot as much as
I had thought I would pee was yeah oh
really
joy marks a little like private drama
thing that's going on here oh god I
trapped myself who's Ted so instead I'm
not dead I'm fine I'm fine
that's Marx I'm what's good stuff I'm so
sorry I'm fine I went around a mountain
and I jumped down if you drop a pail
bury and pet the dog oh he'll follow you
around well I was a little why did I
jump
oh it's fine everything's fine stay at
the hub so that at least one of us
doesn't die again stuff you're on your
own
wait you could build I could build all
right what do I need to build I could
put the space elevator would that help
me up
yep absolutely well an elevator does
kind of sound like what you want I mean
lookout tower technically yeah that
actually probably would work we have any
berries I'm good oh [ __ ] load of berries
I will bring back to you I've also got
another sling saw oh [ __ ] oh my god guys
we can get jump heads that sound so sick
[Music]
I did I did another milestone so that's
cool that's cool that's real good whoa
what did I find a summer sloop I found a
saw more sloop it looks like that s that
everyone drew it in school when they
were bored I found that before I told
you whip now I got a better one how do I
I guess I'd join you guys on my world
I can't equipped anything anymore I
can't gather anything anymore oh I can't
either my inventories broken somehow
because of me oh there goes the game
yeah the game just went yeah
don't worry I hit continue the games
going right back up buddies all right
buddy
thanks buddy oh no oh no oh just your
ramps god don't scare us like that
oh oh no it undid some amount of
progress oh no god damn it if it undid
all of the [ __ ] berries that I have
spent the last 15 minutes gathering most
of them buddy not all of them buddy
don't buddy me pal don't tell me friend
hey everybody at home I'm in the cave oh
[ __ ] - don't worry mark of cover the
line you wait mark are you pink now why
are you pink now you guys switched
colors you think now I don't know man
don't ask me don't go south to feel
North no South wait now you're orange
again mark why'd you change what the
[ __ ] happening who's down here [ __ ] uh
God okay at least I know where I am I'm
not too far off from where I was dead no
I'm not dead what's your right what do
you oh hi why are you here Hey I can't
see the the papo's over this way I think
here there's another slug any together
up here man I went down into an area
that I don't even talk about nice bury
pick for him
thanks man please look up here yeah
there sure yep I'm gonna be on are we
getting some berries fam yeah I got tons
of berries I got tons of berries tons of
nuts I'm gonna bring them back home for
you Bob not for wadies from here you can
see part of the ramp I had to build that
ramp oh you were right there the whole
time
shut up let's go okay alright the dogs I
think over here here's the dog the dogs
right here okay do you have the pail
Barry I do yeah let me split down to one
hey there's pail berries right next to
the base yeah that's cute away on
accident you did you bastard you're pale
Barry drop there's a pail Barry whoa huh
yeah it's going for the pail bear it oh
yeah oh yeah
Oh what is happening I'm taming a dog if
we're gonna have a pet
why did Wayde scream like that though
he's an idiot I that doesn't explain
very much to me mark I need you did not
move cuz I had all of your stuff on me
what and all my stuff on me what I had
all of our stuff on me oh wait what what
you do we had like our resources in my
inventory I found a crevice oh I see the
crevice that you okay that yeah that
that creeps up out of nowhere yeah there
it's just you're running through the
happy [ __ ] fields of joy and then
yeah okay Bob this crevice yeah this
this comes out of no and it's a death
crevice wow that is just death wait
where is your body is it over there I
don't see it oh it's there okay I'm
trying not to fall in all right you're
good you're good I'm gonna bring the dog
back to base okay never mind the dog
stuck the dog now he's going backwards
into the mountain okay he's good he's
good okay this cave crevice is full of
poison so that's a problem um the dog is
just walking backwards moonwalking
backwards
it's moonwalking dude backwards directly
away from me i I'm very confused oh
there goes okay Bob come back home it's
too weird out here cool cool cool cool
cool
howling yeah I don't know about that no
the skitter oh yeah [ __ ] those things
now you know now you know what I was
screaming I know right I know right yeah
it's a problem exactly what Mark said is
exactly what I said Bob come here look
at our pet I have a solution to our pet
no no don't solve our pet don't solve
our vet don't solve the pet don't you
dare huge yes thing takes biofuel I
can't solve anything right now cute
doggie don't with so many why are there
so many green markers on my HUD is the
way just give your slaves time will it
like protect you or whatever I doubt it
but it's cute right yeah it is do this
it's pretty cute
just follow me around okay well that's
good alright God dumped a lot I got a
lot of leaves so I'm gonna try to cram
this down into like bio fuel or
something I don't know I think that
biofuel if you you got a little extras
all right how much biofuel do you want
cuz I'm gonna make a [ __ ] ton Durance
hundreds well that's a high pup puppy so
cute you have any berries mark yeah I
got tons let me the bear it's okay I'll
put them in
oh no wait did you literally lose all
those millions and millions of things of
our cord my way back down Andrew my god
oh look at your doggy I want to come
there you go I want to come too girl
calm calm I don't like this conversation
oh my god guys the chainsaw is so good
for our stinking biofuel oh cool
I'm putting biofuel all the natural
[ __ ] like berries and sea slugs and
stuff is gonna go in this left container
all right I'm just gonna keep
desecrating this land with my chainsaw
okay oh you guys have been pulling
biofuel in these things
oh yeah there's biofuel and all the
generators right now [ __ ] yeah man yeah
I made I made like a [ __ ] ton of it so
they were all maxed out on biofuel while
we were all out being an idiot you were
actually doing work
we do separate independent idiots who
don't need you were being pretty close
together idiots though like if we're
honest oh I want to build jump pads Oh
sick bra oh my god oh oh I found
criteria we could build a node here
built it's nice a nerd you took all my
[ __ ] [ __ ] of course you have the things
then we have we have a manufacturing
just go go to the storage containers and
get all the things but if I go to the
storage container I'll lose we're at
where this is I'll bring it to you
beacon can you make a beacon oh no
that's not the equipment Center this
jointer this conveyor joint I love this
I did that proud of me Dad are you so
proud of you proud of me Dad you've
really done it this time
hey my pinky boy hey is that me I don't
know who that to me
what do you need me to bring you tell me
what you love first full liner all right
I'm bringing you a portable liner do I
need to break the big I'm gonna do if
Tyrion or thing before we can put the
mining thing down the top of it yes yes
I think you do
oh wait I don't think this is a deposit
I think this is just a things not a
deposit once you break this it doesn't
become a deposit doesn't look like
there's more kateri I'm over here right
no this is limestone
every stone okay another deposit of some
kind of a safe it's criterium making my
way to Tyrion that's my song and it's
bad job that's a terrible song what is
this have you gonna see the broken-down
mining station no it's no no I won't
mess with it at all come to me I'm north
of you God give me register beti riyals
and broken-down [ __ ] here be right there
buddy I just need to eat some nuts oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] what is this [ __ ] got a
motor or a bunch of [ __ ] wire early on
which I'm guessing we're supposed to
follow [ __ ] this drop oh no nevermind
repairs needed
okay so there's supplies in here but it
needs 40 megawatts I can just build two
generators right now
that'd be enough right whatever it needs
should I grab all these motors and stuff
oh no man do whatever you want I don't
know man I'm just gonna shove some
leaves in here because I got nothing
better to do I don't have biomass on me
but these are guys that make a fuel
Factory it's gonna be so dope it's
actually really [ __ ] ugly and I'm
sorry but I don't care it's gonna be so
dope I get I give this thing power it's
not what I've got isn't this enough
consuming 40 megawatts yeah it's good
already going into it I don't know is it
need more than anymore
god damn it oh there we go
what the [ __ ] did something just happen
it sounded like that what the [ __ ] I
blew a fuse
what it sound kind of like that what why
what how did that how this mark what are
you doing no no is this a bunch of
[ __ ] oh it's out of leaves no leaves
suck oh we have a bunch of biofuel I
think nice - landscapes leave oh god yes
dude it's someone's [ __ ] command
waves oh my god [ __ ] you're gonna need
to make some sense yeah I know I don't
get what you're saying they're coming
the ball then the ball attacked me
separately from it right so it's
summoned a ball and the ball attacked
you the ball shot flames of hell from
infinite distances the ball the belt it
was balls
average it's an average ball but the
thing that severed the balls big and
it's stumbling toward me and it's passed
oh there's a yellow power slug down to a
yellow power slug why would that be what
would that even be I'm still trying to
get this thing to work properly you guys
see the big archway directly south of
our base right oh no no the south
archway okay really
mark what you do how'd you do I didn't
do anything I'm trying to do I'm trying
my best
it's a big archway it's really hard to
miss it's a real big archway so what are
you jabbering about
big archway south of our base it's like
south south east big archway possible to
miss very big I don't know your
jabbering about do you see the big
archway south east of our [ __ ] base
no I don't clearly no I'm not because
I'm trying to fix up this drop pod it
doesn't work it doesn't work guys it
doesn't work it I'm trying my best
all right it's not working it don't work
why can't I smelt the critérium I need
to smelt it all right what do you smell
I just smelled it where's the smelter I
need to smell this to tear him down why
do you say that like you're a drug
dealer
okay I'm not a drug dealer just needed
right right no I hear you I hear you
wait wait I'm coming to you what do you
want what do you need to tear him down
okay is that all you need right now
hey Mark do you see that big archway
south of base no what yes yes monsters
guarding the yellow okay I'll come over
and you need me to take care of this
thing for you yeah I got I got to build
another storage and put it away because
I'm I'm a little full up I don't want to
risk dying a lot of valuable [ __ ] that I
should not take with us probably a
little for the best
I do we have any kateri I'm smelting
going on right now cuz I could really go
why are you so obsessed with katti reom
like what is because i need the quick
water because oh sorry I'm sorry how do
I get more power over here I need to
power one more smelter I guess you got
to build another bioreactor I can build
one for you okay do you have what we
need
oh yeah I do oh baby yeah I do okay do
you have you have everything I need
yeah I got you I'll watch this yeah
there goes and
a biofuel for you so yeah slam it in
there yeah hang on I'm in it get it oh
it's coming I'm slamming it sucking
sound that is the worst sound I've ever
heard in my life
please stop please continue alright
let's go kill this [ __ ] Bob you want
see wait I didn't put anything away oh
god damn it
well I was busy with the power mark do
you see mark do you see do you see my
factory over here I'm producing biofuel
so much over here does biofuel which
goes to this you cut down so many trees
yeah I [ __ ] on a lot of really
interest I kind of manufacturing we went
to I didn't even know we needed that but
we have it and I love it do I need to
bring anything for this summer I'll just
come along for the ride
except for healing stuff the better I'm
gonna bring my chainsaw and go east
first it will go south from over here
[Laughter]
yeah mark you want to see me get down on
some tree murder yeah okay okay this
might not be the way it's gone just
[ __ ] I just got 23 woods the 60
leaves and
yeah I'm showing these trees who's who's
in charge wha all right wait where's
this stupid creature you were talking
about
oh it's al oh god there's okay well
South I'm just gonna go to Wade's marker
I guess I don't see oh he's like east of
us yeah where was it wait doesn't even
know wait are you are you kidding me no
I'm waiting there I trusted you wait
where are you wait he's here
both of us now right here does not help
oh sweet [ __ ] oh don't come on mark look
down in here almost got like charged by
a thing and blast in there you go back
around this way [ __ ] I don't know yeah I
guess don't worry guys I'm finding it oh
this is death over there don't go that
way that's not the way what wait what
happened I may have just circled all the
way back to base what did it look like
it was a big like you to go down a hill
there was a big clearing and in the
middle of this clearing there was a rock
with a slug on it and around it was a
giant [ __ ] murder beast I see uh I
see a slug I'm gonna go for this slug
seems like I can get to it I got I'm gay
ah [ __ ] I'm getting a slug I see a big
clearing I still don't see any animal
beasts nothing of the like it looks like
a whole lot of nothing what was this it
was this it might have been this down
here hold on I don't think so this isn't
really like it's a little south of but I
see another slug on the other side of a
crevasse we could just get some bounty
boys over here and bounce our way over
we could oh here's another slug on the
rock slugs on rocks here wait this looks
like what you were talking about big
empty valley oh there's another slug
over there yeah there's a fiery spitty
guy oh [ __ ] organs
I got alien organs research the [ __ ] out
of those that's gross
oh yeah mark lost his dog friend when we
crashed right no no no that was after
okay I don't know he's stuck on a rock
somewhere he's like oh like a half way
through a tree I don't know where he's I
feel I found another slug man there's
tons of slugs out here
I was gonna head east I'm gonna find
this place it was near that goddamn
archway I know it what I saw the
archways like hey that's a great marker
I found about that thing oh no Bob I
need your chainsaw services Oh Bob yeah
we cut the trees now yeah I'm stuck on
this tree real bad Oh wasn't over there
I hear something growling really loud oh
gosh Meowth here archway I trying to get
this thing [ __ ] sorry sorry
I mean I'm free oh the slugs still here
yeah it wasn't too far for that top spot
that's right got it here we go and slug
can we reach this thing yes yeah I got
it oh [ __ ] you if it's in the complete
opposite direction I'm gonna be so bad
oh the doggy found limestone he brought
me limestone shut up shut the [ __ ] up
wait what's up waste you shut up
got me front of a dog nothing [ __ ] owner
like Poochie
what way what do you even say I don't
even know what are you talking about
homes where the heart is what do I
suppose I guess alright it's really
unfortunate timing but I gotta be right
back hanging wherever you go there you
are
Ernie I don't know where you are so I
can't protect you also [ __ ] you Wade
mark I found it you did I don't believe
it don't worry alright I'm coming
yeah it's right next to the goddamn
archway I just didn't go far enough
that's real dumb man that's out [ __ ]
okay we don't have our chainsaw on this
I could even see our [ __ ] base from
here okay yeah well this seems like a
big old you problem there's a death star
northwest of our face what do you mean
death star I mean I'm looking at a
goddamn Death Star okay again you you've
been saying this thing about the Death
Star for though this is a big one in the
sky behind the cloud guy behind the
clothes okay yeah
alright I'll be on the way I just saw I
spotted one more green slug I can get so
I'm gonna get this real quick I guess we
should wait for Bob to come see this we
shouldn't wait for Bob you're gonna lose
it again you really good
leave right here Luzi I was a slug just
right here I thought I thought I saw it
not up there I thought I saw a slug
yeah whatever I've lost it Who am I
convinced I'm talking myself I'm talking
what do you think there are thousands of
people watching no there aren't
it doesn't matter anyway alright I'm
coming to you but I'm gonna drop off
some of these slugs just in case I die
that's probably smart I did not do that
nor will I uh there we go okay cool I'm
on the way now all right I got lots of
leaves to protect me I don't think those
are gonna protect you oh [ __ ] I'm at a
hundred thousand likes on my dog toy
video I have to buy 25 toys now my
life's hard for you isn't it I is the
most first world problem ever heard my
entire wow I set a new record for the
number of likes of my videos now I gotta
find my dog some toys that's a
fascinating you should be happy for me
where you tie it was hey I don't see any
I see the slug what are you talking
about behind it there's nothing it's a
rock oh you think it's a rock no that
that's a rock and then it walks amongst
the Stars what the [ __ ] you oh oh yeah
okay you'll stay back it's not safe
alright I'm coming in here we go alright
I'm walking and I even running in this
doesn't seem dangerous man seems
dangerous there's a fireball okay oh oh
oh oh that's big I'm bailing on this I'm
bailing okay you're on your own man
you're on your own Olli [ __ ] we need Bob
Bob all right I'll distract it you grab
the slug [ __ ] whooping flag going for
it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh God
oh my god I got the slug it's a big
[ __ ] baby it's running away oh [ __ ] it
doesn't run away who really wants to
mess up my day haha it's so bad
oh nice to watch from over here like
alright I almost have a slow getting it
right on oodle uh yeah you want some on
your noodle buddy I'll be right there
[ __ ] it's really dad hurts quite a bit
well get your friend in your new Oh God
it really doesn't like me no no it
doesn't ok these almost looks like a
long time to harvest I'm figuring out
its cycle hang on come on oh [ __ ]
the reins on this zapper isn't too good
where'd it go it's just Vader
you're doing the Lord minions work buddy
and I really appreciate that [ __ ]
somehow snuck up behind me where are you
why aren't you here I got the slug one
out of berries I might be in trouble
learn you get you sneaking up on it
alright I'm coming up behind it we're
gonna - mom just shut up stop
complaining get it up I gotta run good
luck wait I'm out here dad he's dead I
killed it well that is a monster yeah Oh
alien organs okay that's alright take
that man never had to doubt never had a
doubt in my mind and never had to doubt
[Music]